[Music]
will mark the viewers a 10 but the pot
toaster on that drive are a serious
drawback I may have whiplash things can
only get better I don't hear from you
for months and then this sudden need to
sell the Tuscan house by last Tuesday
the house to be empty for 20 years we
just cheered place up a bit that's all
Tuscany is a romantic
it'll it's why all my clients come here
you have delivered me a building site
whose walls seem to have been painted by
Mussolini I wouldn't go on the bar if I
were you there's a large weasel in the
sink that's not a euphemism good teeth
the size of a baguette like a rat forget
you're a holiday I'm actually her to
sell an old family house
I love dat house I wanna buy it I can
only pay you in risotto
how many balls do you offer it way the
light hits those windows takes his
breath away
no that's the dust doing that why are
you selling it Jack's memories of the
house or not so good
[Music]
I heard about your mother Jack I'm sorry
don't remember anything
you can't remember and I can't forget
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this house deserves to have his history
element
[Music]
everyone lets everyone down at some
point
how you come back from that - that's
romance rough translation very doable
[Music]
[Music]